في الثاني من فبراير من عام 2022
كانت غرف الاخبار منشغله باحتمالات
التصعيد العسكري بين روسيا واوكرانيا
والتوتر القائم بين الصين وتايوان لكن
ريان وهو ضعيف بين الحياه والموت في بئره
صرف غرف الاخبار عن طبول الحرب التي تقرع
شرقا
لتتصدر ماساته وجهود انقاذه عناوين الصحف
ونشرات الاخبار كما تصدرت اهتمام الراي
العام العربي والعالمي
انا اتواجد في موقع عمليات الانقاذ على
يميني هنالك تهريج ماء موجود لا نعرف كيف
سيجري استخدامه في عمليه الان
قاذ قباله ثلاثه انابيب معدنيه
موضوعه على شكل مستقيم هنالك جرافه واحده
تواصل الاشتغال انا اراها جزئيا نتمنى من
الله ان تبقى الامور على حالها
دون ان يتعرض الفريق
لسقوط اتربه او ما شبه ذلك
[موسيقى]
اول كلمه ريان
باقي للذكرى من نهار اللي
شفت خبر وطرقته كنفكر تفاصيل ديالو الليل
ديالو المكالمات ديال القنوات العالميه في
اربعه الصباح خمسه الصباح الاخبار اللي
كيكون انتظروها كل دقيقه خصك خبر كيتصلوا
بك قنوات
كل مرحله كل وقت صغير من ديك القصه مازال
في الدين ديالو اظن مستحيل مستحيل ينزول
لان عشنا ليلا ونهار كنت كنعاس
الساعه كنقسم ثلث ساعات
جوج في 24 ساعه